afghanistan ist für mich ein thema was
ich lange
beobachtet wo ich lange berichtet habe
viele viele wochen monate in den
vergangenen zehn jahren immer wieder und
zuletzt im august und im juli und ich
habe das gefühl dass wir afghanistan
wieder vergessen ich bekomme immer noch
jeden tag nachrichten von menschen die
dort festsitzen die sagen dass sie nicht
raus kommen die eigentlich mit der
bundeswehr gearbeitet haben mit dem
außenministerium und es bedeutet für
diese menschen lebensgefahr jeden tag
aufs neue lebensgefahr weil sie gegen
die taliban sind weil sie für außen für
ausländer gearbeitet haben für
deutschland gearbeitet haben und ich
glaube dass wir dringend das thema
wieder mehr in den fokus rücken müssen
das machen wir hierbei bild denn nach
dieser sendung gibt es eine doku eine
dokumentation von mir
über afghanistan
paul also ich bin gespannt darauf die zu
sehen und wieder heute oder im stream
etwas später dann auch ich weiß auch was
du da auf sich genommen hast tatsächlich
da hinzufahren und mehrfach dann auch du
bist jetzt zurückgewiesen worden einmal
als du so kann man schon sagen oder
einsatz des lebens deportiert hass
berichtet ist als letzter deutscher
journalist vor ort dann auch dort und
uns eben mit gegeben hast was da gerade
passiert und insofern ist das eine
unglaublich wichtige dokumentation wir
müssen da weiter bleiben ich war ja
so als regierungssprecher aktiver als
wir damals in entscheidenden schritt
gemacht haben nach nine eleven gesagt
haben solidarität ist uneingeschränkt
mit den usa und deswegen weil die
afghanistan ausgemacht hatten als hort
der das versteck von osama bin laden die
npd mit 20 jahre später war ich auch
einige male mit da du hast viel öfter
aber es da zu sehen in den laufenden
jahren wie die taliban immer mehr macht
hat und wie wir leider auch als
regierungen die danach kamen immer mehr
macht den taliban
zugestanden haben als letztes ich kann
mich erinnern an einer reise mit frank
walter steinmeier dann hin als er noch
außenminister war da wollten wir eine
schule besuchen mit männer mädchen und
jungs die mädchen waren aber nicht da
weil die taliban die fern gehalten hat
dann wollten dieses symbol nicht das war
jahre vor dem sturz von kabul da war
schon erkennbar welche macht ausüben
dass die solche symbole eben
unterwandern und eigentlich hätte man da
spätestens sagen müssen keine
verhandlungen mehr das war schwer weil
die usa natürlich parallel verhandelt
haben aber das ist eine große schuld die
wieder auf uns geladen haben und wir
müssen etwas tun um den menschen gesagt
dass über unsere aufmerksamkeit ökonomie
muss man sagen ein paar wochen
hingeschaut und immer berichtet live so
zu sagen was da passiert ist und jetzt
muss man auch selbstkritisch sagen auch
bei uns sozusagen ist das thema
natürlich wieder nach hinten wer beim
film nachts nicht vergessen afghanistan
gesprochen der stadtbücherei hier der
stadt hervor gesagt hat also bei uns
nicht da aber ja ich meine sozusagen
insgesamt natürlich die die leute sind
abgestumpft sie haben so viele konflikte
auf der ganzen welt ist irgendwie gar
nicht mehr nachkommen und wände aber ich
glaube es ist wahnsinnig wichtig dass
weiter berichtet aber deshalb das glaube
ich ganz gut dass heute auch im rahmen
der sondierungsgespräche auf bundesebene
die die verabredung getroffen wurde
darüber nachzudenken entweder in enquete
kommission einzusetzen die die 20 jahre
insgesamt betrachtet und auf der anderen
seite möglicherweise sogar ein
untersuchungsausschuss der sich die mit
der frage des truppenabzugs noch mal
auseinander setzt also um das
aufzuarbeiten um es auch zu erinnern
wachzuhalten wir könnten das ja zwar
instrumentarien sein ich glaube so um
dass um das zu ergänzen
neben der bereitschaft mit den taliban
zu reden immer weiter kontakte zu
erhalten gab es natürlich einen zweiten
für mich eigentlich noch größeren fehler
dass der westen ohne genauer
hinzuschauen milliarden in ein korruptes
regime in kabul gesteckt hat nicht
erkennen das natürlich kein soldat sein
leben für solche leute einsetzt wie man
dann gesehen ist und sofort davon
gelaufen und das ist ja nicht in
afghanistan zum ersten mal passiert ich
muss lieber paul da noch anmerken wir
reden hier eigentlich selten über
journalismus aber wenn du schon mal hier
sitzt wir beobachten seit jahren wie du
an diesen brennpunkten und gerade dort
unterwegs bist und jetzt wieder und zwar
im direkten gespräch mit taliban führern
und das ist erstens eine wahnsinnig
wichtige informationsquelle weil man die
sonst nicht mehr hat gibt ganz wenige
journalisten die das tun und du warst
glaube ich jetzt wieder mal der erste
und einzige der das getan haben nicht
der einzige neuer da christoph reuter
hatte man wollte ich gerade den hagel
viele kollegen also ich finde du dich
nicht zu viel dich viel lob für viele
nicht aber ein paar seien es aber
jedenfalls du bist immer vorne dran und
das ist eine ganz außerordentliche
leistung es gibt nicht nur versagen im
journalismus es gibt auch so was was
mutig es und wichtig ist und wenn ich
dir mal als kollege sagen danke ich dir
danke schön was mir sozusagen in dem
ganzen thema
wahnsinnig in unternehmen brennt ist die
frage ist dann wie gehen wir zweiter mit
dem land um ja also er hat droht eine
hungersnot am ende ist sozusagen eine
wahnsinnige wirtschaftlicher kollaps
also die menschen haben nicht wir haben
keine nahrungsmittel mehr dort ja das
ist sozusagen die frage wie gehen wir
damit um also was machen wir mit den
diplomatischen beziehungen sollen wir da
wieder eine botschaft haben oder nicht
ich glaube schon ja am ende müssen wir
uns mit den realitäten
auseinandersetzen und müssen da wieder
eine botschaft eröffnet und die taliban
auch die sich nämlich als erstes als die
kabuler dort hatten in die zentralbank
gegangen im keller oder wieder wo sind
die jetzt also goldvorräte bis dahin
gesagt haben ja die liegen in new york
also da war schon eine große
überraschung da das heißt auch die
werden mit anderen nationen trotz ihrer
radikalität zusammenarbeiten müssen und
wir müssen da das sich durch irgendeinen
weg finden es ist schwer weil die nicht
ablassen werden von ihrem unrechtsregime
und ihre radikalität auch mal
durchsetzen ist das so das wollte ich
jetzt als frage formulieren du bist
jetzt seit dem umsturz in afghanistan
mehrfach dort gewesen wir erinnern uns
wir haben auch mal darüber geredet am
anfang gab es frauen demonstration in
kabul ganz mutige frauen die auf ihren
rechten bestanden haben die sind dann
gibt geknüppelt worden und so weiter
was ist heute der zustand sitzen da sind
die alle in haft sind in großer zahl
menschen hingerichtet worden von dem wir
nichts wissen die die als hochnäsig zu
sich gesucht haben und dann hingerichtet
haben und wie ist die haltung dieser
menschen sind die nach wie vor
entschlossen das land zu verlassen oder
sagen die wir werden hier bleiben dann
werden versuchen was an den zuständen zu
verändern also was man sozusagen sagen
kann es gab keine massenhinrichtung von
den mann reichen kann aber es gibt ganz
ganz viele vermisste ich alleine kenne
viele leute die ich dort in afghanistan
den vergangenen jahren kennengelernt
habe die vermisst sind man weiß nicht wo
sie sind man erlebt dass viele dinge
außerhalb kabuls passieren dass die
medienöffentlichkeit ist noch in kabul
sozusagen das in den provinzen schlimme
dinge passieren dass dort menschen
hingerichtet werden dass sie verschleppt
werden usw dass es tatsächlich an der
tagesordnung was die menschen angeht
insgesamt viele verstecken sich noch und
sagen sie sind hier in ihrem versteck
irgendwo in kabul haben sich eine
wohnung gesucht oder bei freunden
untergekommen sie wollen immer noch weg
also ich versuchen ich kriege täglich
nachrichten die sagen wir müssen auch
diese liste in der bundeswehr oder beim
außenministerium rauszukommen ja das ist
glaube ich ein ganz großes problem was
die taliban angeht haben die sehr viele
in taliban probleme ära die kämpfen mit
einer andere die ganze zeit es gibt
nicht nur wirkliche irakkrieg eine
marktstruktur und das macht es
wahnsinnig kompliziert und mit denen
überhaupt zu fahren während man das
einfangen der islamischen staat erlebt
mit blutigen aktionen ist ja jetzt noch
zusehen oder sehr ist er dass er zu
sehen ja also das ist eigentlich dass
die große gefahr dass sozusagen eis
gegen die taliban dort eine struktur
aufbaut und am ende für die leute die
sagen die taliban sind ihnen nicht mehr
radikal genug so absurd das klingen mag
dass sie dann zu wechseln und am ende
ist es ganz ganz groß wird wie sieht
denn die handlungsempfehlung aus die
handlungsempfehlung paul ronzheimer also
nach dem lagebild also ich würde sagen
dass wir dringend eine botschaft wieder
eröffnen sollten dass wir dringend
sozusagen dort präsenz zeigen mussten
das würden wir nicht da uns raushalten
dürfen in doha sein und irgendwie sache
okay wenn ich angst und wollen irgendwie
licht und so wir müssen da sein und ich
glaube egal ist so grausam es ist ja was
die taliban teilweise machen glaube ich
müssen wir den menschen helfen dass sie
nahrungsmittel zu mittag damit soll ich
schon vor hunger weglaufen
wie sieht es dann weißt du dich an der
grenze zum iran aussieht ist die grenze
wie sich ein riesen lang ist die dicht
gemacht soweit man das kann ist dies
also verzieh dich zu machen hat nicht
wirklich funktioniert und es gibt einen
flüchtlingsstrom der einsätze langsam
wird türkei und griechenland das ist
also ich habe kollegen dietrich 19 die
sagen dass da immer mehr
willkommen in diesen tagen
[Musik]